how does a guy as my name is Vicenta
welcome back to my game entrance series
it's a lot of time we talked about
blending make sure the each check out of
that video if you haven't already and
today we're gonna be taking a look at
our code and figuring out a better way
to do something that we did before seems
like this is kind of the way the
programming goes in general you write
some code and then a little ways down
the road you figure out that well
actually this kind of sucks there's a
better way to do this now of course this
isn't me specifically like accidentally
writing bad code or than being like oh
my gosh that's just as such a better way
to do this that I've missed it's more or
less me just building hazel
incrementally or rather I guess
iteratively and that's very common when
you're building software to iterate over
what you've already got and then change
it as time goes on the reason is that
our goal here kind of is to try and
build up like an MVP a Minimum Viable
Product will say as quickly as possible
and then kind of retrace our steps and
make things a little bit cleaner so I
mentioned this a really long time ago I
think when we created our first triangle
where basically what I want to do is I
don't want to spend a year writing code
that is then finally going to produce a
triangle for us but the car is gonna be
rock-solid that's not fun for anyone no
one does that really I've never heard of
anyone doing that before because it's
it's weird what you want to do is write
that triangle basically as quickly as
possible right not being completely
crazy right I mean if we wanted to we
could just write everything in one file
and we wouldn't have an engine but we
have a triangle right I'm not saying do
that I'm just saying get that triangle
as quickly as possible in a reasonable
way right and then we can retrace our
steps go over that code and improve it
and make it more robust and just better
and that's kind of what we're doing here
in the shader episode right we wanted to
basically load a shader and use the
shader all within like 20 minutes and
just have it running and that's it right
what we're gonna do today is retrace our
steps as to how we actually you know
compiled shaders and basically change it
so that instead
just taking in two strings a vertex
source string and then a fragment source
string we're gonna load it all from one
file and this is going to be super
simple in fact
I've made a video in the OpenGL series
is called how I deal with shaders in
OpenGL check that out because it's gonna
shed some light into what we're gonna be
doing here today it's gonna be slightly
different than what I did in that video
but like for all intents and purposes it
is going to be the same so recently we
talked about assets and we kind of
introduced textures as our first asset
and that was fantastic but now what we
can do is actually go over to our engine
and take a look at other things that
should be assets namely shaders right
shaders should not be kind of just
defined the strings maybe it would be it
should like it should be possible for
your API to support that because who
knows maybe someone wants to build an
application in hazel and they want to
have a little text editor I am GUI or
maybe a custom control that's like a
text editor and then you can like write
some shader code in and then you can
just like see the effects of that live
almost like shared a toy or something
like that as an as a hazel application
that should be possible right now I want
to make hazel as open as possible I want
to make the API as powerful as possible
so that you can do things like that so
in other words we probably still want to
keep the the I was going to say
opportunity but we want to keep the
capability of compiling shader code from
strings we still want to keep that but
we want to introduce them another way of
creating shaders and that's going to be
from a single file a shadow file now
look if we talk about other api's other
rendering API is not just OpenGL
typically speaking like you wouldn't
compile shader source code very often
like you would have maybe pre-compiled
byte data essentially that is kind of
your binary shader and then you just you
know run that for example you well you
could compile it on a target platform
because commonly you know if we look at
large-scale games right what they'll do
is they'll actually ship with they'll
they'll be like a billion permutations
and then based on your target hardware
it will take the appropriate sections
and based on what graphics settings
you've chosen as well it'll take
appropriate like shader blocks and then
combine them all into a shade up locally
on your computer right and then
take that as like a caged shader and
then that's the binary daughter it will
load at runtime that's typically what
happens obviously we're nowhere near at
that stage yet but for us you know we're
gonna kind of ignore that as far as I am
concerned I don't think OpenGL supports
binary shaders I'm not a hundred percent
sure I haven't go on that fine to OpenGL
itself because as I mentioned like I've
been just quite a simple API I don't
usually like dealing with it too often
but for this for the purposes of this
it's just fantastic
obviously I'm not hating on Arkham jail
at all I'm just saying that
professionally I haven't like gone into
there too far because you know like no
one really ships games for Windows on
OpenGL like that's not just not
something that's done anyway my point
though is that you know withs pervy
maybe you can do something like that I'm
not 100% sure how all that works so if
you know leave a comment below because I
will I will investigate this and I'm
sure that a quick Google search could
clear this out for me but that's besides
the point so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna take a look at creating
shaders as a resource today we're just
gonna be really really cool it allows a
few things right first of all these are
strings right now they're string the
static strings in our memory right
that's fine but the cool thing about
having files is that it's almost like
we've introduced a scripting language
what we should be able to do
theoretically and I mean well we will be
able to do this 100% but theoretically
what we should be able to do is actually
take that file make some changes to the
shader go back to hazel and we should
see those changes live right there's no
reason for that not to work all we have
to do is recompile that shader right
done reload the file recompile the
shader and then that activate that
shader instead right I mean if there are
errors in the shader maybe don't
recompile it maybe just display a
message being like quoting from Paul
shader but still keep that original
shader until we actually get one that
compiles successfully but my point is
reloadable shaders something that should
be really easy with this system so there
are benefits to it it's not just the
fact that I don't want strings here and
I want separate files it's also which
would be necessary who wants to have
strings as shaders in their code anyway
but my point is it comes with other
benefits that you may not see I want to
give a huge thank you to all the patrons
that made this series possible patron
record for such the show note is the
best way to support the series and
everything that I do here on YouTube
people who do help support the series
get access to something called the hazel
development branch which is a way more
advanced version of hazel with like 3d
rendering and all of that fun stuff I
have already done this kind of
reloadable shader system in that code
base so this will kind of be inspired by
that and in fact I'll be taking code
from dropping from hazel dev in order to
make this stuff happen anyway let's get
into the card and see how we can change
our shader workflow so these strings
here are exactly what I'm talking about
I don't want to have these two strings
here it's kind of annoying right I still
want to be able to do this if I really
really have to but I don't want to have
these two strings here I want to have
them in a file let's talk about what
that file might look like I think the
best way to write this kind of stuff is
to first determine what is the end
result right it's the same thing as when
you're running an API you know instead
of going in and trying to create a
shader class just start typing code like
shade of you know create and then you
know okay I guess I'll pass in like my
files so for example in this case we
could have assets
shaders and then well let's just say
what are we actually using out of the
shades we're using the texture shader so
we'll say we'll say something like
texture don't kill a cell right and then
that's it that's that's kind of how we
want our API to look so in that same
spirit all right what we want to do is
do the same thing with the shader so I'm
gonna create a shirt at first before we
even take a look at the code that we
need to both load it and read the file
from our disk and then also kind of
split it up into two shaders because as
I mentioned of course OpenGL wants two
different strings but we're gonna supply
everything in a single file who's gonna
be super clean that way okay so if I
show all files here we take a look at
sandbox we've got assets textures I'm
gonna make another folder here called
shaders because that's where a lot more
about shaders to live and then inside
there I'm gonna make a new item I can
just use visual studio to do this or of
course you could just do this in your
file explorer if you wanted to and we're
gonna call this texture don't jello sell
now I've called a jello sell
specifically I don't want to call it
like dot shader or anything like that
you can call it anything you want August
gonna be read in as a string but the
reason I pulled your cell because this
specifically is GLSL code that's
important because in the future it's
very likely that we'll stick with a
single shading language most likely hlsl
which is like the directx shading
language and then from there we can
cross compile it into GLSL if we need to
using something like [ __ ] but anyway
that's way in the future we aren't going
to bother with that now but basically
what I'm saying is we still want to keep
this is gel cell because it's going to
be useful that way now in the future in
the more immediate future before we talk
about cross compiling and other api's
it's very likely that we'll actually
modify GLSL and kind of turn it into our
own shading language because it's not
that difficult to do and basically it
will just enable us to have a few more
like keywords in the shading language
that will help hazel kind of know the
intended usage of certain areas so
that's something that will probably
happen I would say sooner then like
cross compiling and all that fun stuff
but we'll see because I don't want to
promise anything because I haven't
really gotten around to that yet anyway
so let's look at what we're doing so
what we're dealing with our texture
shader we'll start with that one right
what I'll do is I'll copy this is the
fragment shader alright I'll copy that
paste it here and then I will do the
same thing with this vertex shader and
I'll paste it in so we've got two
shaders here obviously we need a way to
distinguish between what type of shaders
they actually are right so this is a
vertex shader and then this is a
fragment shader the way that I like to
do this is just to type in the word type
with like a hash here just the same way
that we have hash version is like a
preprocessor kind of directive we have
the same thing with type and then I'll
just type in the time right so this will
be about text and then for this one I'm
gonna call it fragment this is the
fragment shader
now you might call it a pixel shader
that's fine I'll probably end up
supporting both keywords but basically
what this will do is have a little
indicator for us being like okay this is
good the following is going to be a new
shader type keep going until you either
see another type or until the end of the
file right and then the next key word
here is going to be the type of shader
that it is so vertex fragment pixel you
know geometry whatever compute whatever
it might be in the future will kind of
support that as well and then that's it
now how lovely is it can I just point
out to have both of your
single file right I mean I hate having
separate files for shaders DirectX has
it usually as a single file as well
which is super useful but OpenGL likes
to split it up very commonly people will
load they're two different shaders as
two different files that's super
annoying and I don't see the point of
that at all you could argue that yes you
could reuse the vertex shader for many
pixel shaders but in my experience like
I don't know I don't think that's that
useful because commonly when I've been
modifying the pixel shader to do
something else I've had to modify the
vertex shader as well like they've maybe
I've got different uniforms maybe I've
got a different vertex layout that all
requires modifying that vertex shader
anyway so commonly I wouldn't say that
there have been too many cases in my
life personally where I've been like
I've reused the same vertex shader for
like five hundred fragment shaders for
example that's not gonna happen
typically right obviously if you have a
system in which you you know assemble
shaders from blocks live then you'll
very commonly reuse the same vertex
block but that's something completely
different and in that case you would
still load the one file anyway so it
doesn't it doesn't matter okay anyway
texture there we've got the texture
shader fantastic I'm just gonna delete
it from here because I'm that bold and
of course we will get this to work today
so if we go over here to basically I'm
just gonna hop over into share to create
I'm going to add another trader career
so I'm not taking away the easiest in
functionality because I do want to keep
that in case we want it and then Windows
10 just go away please
I really really close to switching to
Mac or Linux so there's our share to
create function we've got our path I'll
just call this file path to make it
super explicit we'll come over here I'll
just implement this function here
quickly and follow along with this it
really should be the first function I
think because we did put it in that
order in the header file then I'll copy
this and I think we'll just have this
across I think this just becomes file
path it just becomes
I think this just becomes filepath and
that should be it okay
I've been shall shout it from afar pop
done sorry if we hop on over to OpenGL
shader again we will duplicate this
constructor and just make it a file path
constructor and then if we go over to
the CVP file we can take a look at what
we need to do so we do everything in a
constructor right now which is fine but
not really what we want so what I'll do
is I will probably make a function a
private function here called compile and
this is what we'll do basically
everything that the constructor did so
compile and then we probably want to
take in the source code so let's take a
look at how we're gonna split this up
first and in fact what I'll do is I'll
kind of have probably what will happen
is both of these constructors will
actually intellisense takes forever
both of these constructors will actually
just call into that compile method and
in this this already has it in the right
format which is fantastic but then the
other constructor which will which we
will create right now the other
constructor will of course have to read
the file first so we'll have our file
pub yeah okay so as from reading the
file let's get that out of the way
quickly so basically what we want to do
is take in an input file stream now look
I mean in the future a file system in a
game engine is a very complex topic like
you'd usually have like a virtual file
system you usually have to abstract this
because obviously it's gonna be
different on Android or iOS versus
Windows and so you might need to like
mount certain directories treat it like
as a virtual file system you know you
might have all of your assets sort in
one binary blob and then you might have
to go in there and I'll probably
probably be compressed as well and so
there's a bunch of things that you need
to consider but obviously we're gonna
keep it we're gonna be keeping it super
simple here and really what's gonna use
an iron stream this code in the final
ever version of hazel right
hypothetically I don't think this will
make it right it will be completely
different in that I mean realistically
we might even have a per platform
filesystem so we'd be using something
like Windows like create file you know
whatever to actually do everything and
we need to do instead of using the cpp
library so don't worry if you think this
is fine
oh did something not but if you're gonna
get the job down there for now and
probably for the foreseeable future for
a while because it's definitely gonna be
good enough for us
so we'll take in a file path and then we
will just tell it the between input file
and then that we want it to be read as
binary now you might be like why on
earth you reading a text file is binary
it's because we don't want to do any
processing to it right this is gonna be
completely just in the format that we
want it to be in we want to read all of
the binary data so that we actually get
all the data from the file we don't want
single us to take it and try and
interpret it as a string that's
completely unnecessary and something
that I definitely don't want to have so
we'll just include air stream here and
we should be good so if that input file
stream was successfully opened if it's
not we could assert it because really
you shouldn't be trying to load files
that don't exist
so what I'll probably do is just write a
little warning here
the reason I'm writing it well I guess
we will make it an arrow the reason I'm
not asserting is because maybe this
might be permissible like you might try
and load a whole bunch of shaders if
they don't succeed that could be fine
like we should still be able to handle
what I guess anyway could not open file
and then I guess we will supply the file
file as a monument yeah okay that should
be pretty good
whoops totally cannot close that quote
correctly all right so now now we've got
our core error which is great so the
first thing I want to do is actually see
what the file size is and then our
strategy is gonna be the greatest string
that is that big and then load
everything into the string so we'll do
in seek G and we'll go to the very end
of the file so offset of zero and then
to iOS and right this will go to the
very end of the file so now our kind of
file pointer is at the end of the file
then ideally I want to like basically
create my string so we'll actually
create the string here we'll call this
um we're probably I call it result and
we'll move this into another into
another function
because it's getting a bit too messy
here anyway so we'll resize the result
here and this will just be G which will
basically tell us where that actual
pointer is so thus since the pointer to
the file is at the very end it is the
size of the file now we need to
basically bring us back to the start
so begin and then we can read the file
by just calling in dot read we're going
to read it into the very first we'll
just give it a pointer to the beginning
of that string and then of course the
size of the string which is the size the
file will be our size so we're reading
in that many bytes is going around to
the string we've obviously resized the
string here to the size that we want and
that is pretty much it and then
obviously at the end we will close that
stream okay
that's it now all we need to do is
process this result so what I'll do is I
will call I will make another function
here called a rate file and of course
will take in a file path to read I'll
copy this and I'll put it probably just
below the constructor here
I may be bled the destructor and opengl
shadow read file and then this will just
basically be our the contents of this
right ok cool so there we go
at the end we'll return results so we'll
return an empty string if this was not
able to be read which is fine and then
we can call read file and then now from
pop off we have our string for
processing so we'll have this our data
source okay there we go so now we need
to actually split it up into the
appropriate number of shaders so we have
our shader which has two different types
here
we now need a function that will
basically read through that string and
then based on these two types split it
up into two strings where one string is
this section over here and then the
other string is this section over here
so let's go ahead and implement that
what I'll do is I'll create another
function here before compile I'll call
this pre process and the
of course taking our shader source code
so string sourced now what we want to do
is split it up into multiple shaders as
I've mentioned so we need a way to
organize this we could just use
something like a pair or a tuple or we
could create a struct that has all of
our different shader source codes
however we don't even know how many we
want right because this could contain
two shaders vertex shader fragment
shader it could contain more right for
example we could have a geometry shader
in there as well therefore that will be
three shares right so because of that
what I'll do is I'll actually use a map
specifically an unordered map and what
this will do unordered map is basically
mapper map us from a GL enum which is
going to be the shader type and we're
storing it as a GL enum so that we can
immediately just give it to OpenGL as
like so basically the key of this map is
going to be the type of shader that we
compiled and then obviously the string
which is gonna be the source code so
that's gonna be our pre process and when
we go into compile that's what we will
take in right we'll take the simplest
reference and this will just be our
shader sources okay so back into C++
land well I mean we're always in C++ but
I mean into the CPP file we will
implement this function and now let's
talk about how this is going to work
okay so what I've done here is I've
cheated a little bit I have taken this
code from the hazel development brush
because it's already written and there's
no point in me writing this for you I
will explain all of it in a minute there
is one function that still needs to be
implemented and that is the shader type
from string that's really simple all
that does is just convert a string to a
shader type super simple function will
implement that right now in fact I'll
just do this at the top of this file
doesn't even need to be in the header
file we'll have a static GL enum and
then let's see what was the name of that
function datatype from string as well of
course take in a constant string which
is going to be our type and then if the
type is going to do equal vs.
so this is just the the final kind of
tie price of what we see at the end of
this so vertex fragment all of that kind
of stuff so
so if it's third text we'll just return
GL vertex shader and then if it's going
to be fragments I'll actually toughest
down because it's gonna be a long line
if it's gonna be fragments all will
support pixel as I mentioned before will
return a GL fragment shader and of
course if we had other shader types then
we would return that as well if that
doesn't we haven't returned anything
we'll just do a poor set here and we'll
basically just say there's an unknown
data type and then I guess we'll
actually have the type here as well we
can't format this can we yeah that's
gonna be a little bit annoying okay in
that case I will just write unknown
shadow type we need to probably fix that
so that we can actually format things
like this but anyway there we go unknown
chair type and then we'll return to 0
for our value okay sounds good we're
back here let's talk about how this code
works it's really quite simple so the
first thing that we do is actually
figure out basically the token that
we're going to split on so type is the
keyword that we're looking for hash type
that's basically that basically tells us
that after that token we're going to the
next token is going to be the type of
shadow right so what we do is we try and
look for the type token through all of
our shader source code right at this
point this is all of this code and then
if we find it right over fact while we
keep finding it because obviously we'll
look for it as many times as it exists
we'll start with the top of the file and
we'll kind of go down and for all of the
types we want to find them all so while
we still have found that type token so
for the first time that we run through
this code it will be literally on the
first line right what we'll do is we'll
find the new line the first instance of
a new line or a carriage return this
will find either right which is what we
want and then that gives us the position
of that new line if it doesn't exist
we'll just print off this that is a
syntax error because clearly what we've
basically done is I don't know we've
just we've probably got something like
this or we've got no like lines after it
which is a little bit weird so we'll
definitely
there and then basically begin again is
interesting it's going to be the
position right of this so in other words
this will literally be zero because the
first time that we look through this
you'll see that in this case it doesn't
necessarily have to be zero in this case
it's literally the first the first thing
that we see in our file is that but you
can put other stuff here you might have
a comment here that says you know in
fact let's do this we'll have a comment
here that says basically the texture
shader right just so that it kind of
explains to us what the shader actually
is in this case obviously we have this
stuff first and then eventually we have
type so once we do run into type that's
going to be the position from there we
take the length of the token which is
and I should really probably just move
this over here because I keep
referencing it so many times so I'll
keep this here hopefully you guys can
see everything so we're basically
looking for the type token so this type
token length is going to be literally
five right because it's five characters
so we advanced past the beginning
position when we advanced five
characters so we're now here and then
plus one so that brings us obviously
gives us a space between the two that
brings us to type at vertex now yes I
mean look if you really wanted to be
pedantic about what that's not my work
right unless you trim the whitespace
later which you also could do so in this
case we're just basically making sure
that you have to have one space
otherwise you'll get like some certain
it won't work or it'll crash you thought
because I haven't tested that but
whatever so string type
so what we'll do here is we'll basically
extract that type so we basically take a
substring from beginning to end of line
- beginning right so begin of course
being the beginning of your token so
from here to the end of line right which
is going to be right here and then if it
isn't exactly vertex or fragment or
pixel right we're gonna say invalid
shader type specified now of course
that's a that's just in the cert and I
could easily just come up here and try
and get the shadow type from string and
if it returns zero we assert so we could
do that could be a way to optimize this
in fact I think I will do that so we'll
basically say shader type from string
and then type because we know that if it
returned if it returns zero
that in itself will check right it'll do
this course out here but also it will
cache another as
because this will return zero and by
asserting it we're saying it has to not
be zero so envelop the trailer type
specify so yes if you leave a space like
this right it will in fact return in
assert for you instead of crashing waves
good alright next line position we find
the next five first not off right so we
find the next line and then from there
we try and find the next type token
right which is going to be which is
going to be type fragment in this case
and then if we find it all right we do
it we don't bunch of stuff here so let
me just maybe tap this down and then try
and split this up by parameter so you
guys can see better basically what we're
doing here is taking a substring from
the next line position which is
basically the beginning of line four for
the first time that we run this right
we're taking a substring from that to
hopefully what is the end either the end
of the file or the end of like until we
find the next shadow type which is what
this code is doing and then after that
we'll of course go back up here and see
if position is still not n pause which
means that it found another token and
we'll repeat rinse repeat the process
again so that's kind of how we end up
splitting this into several types now of
course look I mean this code is not
bulletproof and more claiming that it is
you probably want to maybe clean this up
but for my purposes of course all I'm
doing is splitting this up as quickly as
possible and that this is pretty simple
and it works for most cases but of
course if you do something stupid and
you have like too many spaces or you
just do the wrong thing it will most
likely assert and let you know okay cool
I'll just clean this up the kinetic like
the way that looks and we can finally
start feeding this stuff into a compiler
so pre process returns our unordered map
so now that we've got that so I'll come
over here so about the shader sauce
right then we're going to get the shader
sources I'll call it right so maybe I'll
just call this sauce just to make it a
little bit easier to read so we'll do
our pre process which by the way could
do other thing in this pipe called a pre
process could do other things as well if
we have other like maybe we have more
than just type in one split on
we have other kind of metadata that we
want to read out so we can definitely do
that as well we'll give it the source
and now what we want to do is to compile
we want to pass our shader sources okay
and so compile is going to take this
entire code that we had in the
constructor we're going to get rid of it
and then we're going to go down into
compile which I don't think we created
acted weak so avoid OpenGL shader
compiled and then yeah it is our shader
sources will paste this in and basically
what we want to do is convert this into
some kind of a loop that will iterate
over our shader sources map right so
we'll say for what are the value K babe
shader sources so just to make this
super obvious we'll have our GL enum
shader type right but it's gonna be a
video first and then we'll have our STD
string shader so we can just I mean
obviously talking about shaders so we'll
just hey type and its source and then
that will be key value second I'm taking
that by reference of course because we
don't want to copy a string now since we
are taking this in as a Const right
which is fine cuz we don't wanna
multiply it we'll just have to label
this as a Const string source okay cool
so now that's done what when you want to
do is instead of creating this a vertex
shader right if I just copy that's not
probably get rid of the comments now
it's pretty clear what's happening
anyway glu int will say data type right
or rather watershed shader so this is
going to be our GL creator and then
instead of our vertex shader of course
we're not taking in the type so we're
creating a shadow of that type right
next line occurred actually we'll just
grab this whole section here and we'll
kind of work through it so next line of
course we're taking in these sources as
a C string so this will just be a source
C string instead of shader source we now
have a sorry it's at a vertex shader we
now have shader right and then this
which what did that used to be so we had
source
alright this used to be called source I
say so we took that as
we'll just say sauce see string to make
that a bit more obvious okay and then
the comparator which is gonna be our
shader and this is obviously going to be
shader again for the compiled status
we'll get the log leg pulled all of that
stuff shader now in this case it says
the vertex shader compilation fails so
we definitely need to have a way to
convert that to a string if we add the
opposite of this function we could
probably use it I'm probably not too
fast about this we could just say like
shader compilation failure right this is
just directly from that opengl wiki and
then obviously we have an assert here so
if so it will kind of put a breakpoint
in here and when we break here we can
easily take a look at what the type is
and then see what it was so it would be
nice in the future to know what what
failed exactly but I'm not gonna bother
with that now okay so we'll kind of get
rid of these comments and I think that's
it so if you look at this and we have a
return yeah I don't know if you
necessarily want time maybe we'll just
make it a break so that we don't keep
compiling the register shaders but
anyway so that should be it there's
nothing here in specific to vertex
traders as you can see we're basically
compiling whatever the type is right and
then we just create our shader and then
we use that everywhere and that is
pretty much it right so this will this
this kind of for loop now should compile
both our vertex and fragment shaders
which is pretty cool so we'll get rid of
everything else you see how long this is
we don't need any of that anymore
if we come back over here now there's
actually other stuff that we need right
so now we have that gel create program
and when we need to attach all of our
shaders and then we need to link them
and then we need to do all of that and
then check the link status of course so
this stuff can be fixed by simply
reordering this stuff right so GL
attached shader for example if the
compilation actually succeeded we can
just attach it to our program by just
attaching a shader to program calling
attach here after we've checked whether
or not is successfully compiled now for
that to happen the program has to be up
here so what we'll do is we'll just take
this and move it up here totally fine so
we create a program now the thing is if
it failed maybe we want to set the
render ID to something else and
program because of that I think what
I'll do is I will keep that Glu into
program up here and then we'll only
assign the render ID to do the program
at the end so that way we'll never end
up with a valid shader program I'll just
be like zero or whatever even though I
think zero is valid it will just be kind
of not set until we know that everything
worked out so that way we can easily
check whether or not a shader is in a
like successful state or not
so this disappears now everything else I
think should work the only thing that
doesn't is this whole detached shader
and delete shader business so we need to
basically keep track of the OpenGL
shader IDs super easy to do right we
know how many there are here so what we
should be able to do is easily just
create a vector or something like this
you could create the the thing is it's
dynamic so we can't really create it on
the stack and once we use like alakay or
something like that so we'll just have a
vector of GL enums right and this will
be called our will say GL shader IDs
right and then into here we'll put we'll
make it so that is the right size so
shader sources dot size will be the size
of this right so now we've done that all
we need to do is come down over here and
then once we've actually created this we
basically just need to push this push
this back into our shader IDs
okay so that's the enum being pushed
back so now we have a list of these now
I can't remember if this actually
creates that many elements or if it
resizes it to that capacity because we
want the one that resizes it so we'll
see if this works if it doesn't we'll
change it to be don't resize because I
don't know at the API I remember that
well okay so that's pretty much it now
if we want to like delete shaders or
whatever we just need to have a full
loop that goes through all of that so
ordered for order I don't we can just
yeah full order will say ID in GL shader
IDs right GL shader IDs will go through
and just delete that and basically we'll
do the same thing for this section here
with detached shaders so we basically
just do
that okay so now we're successfully
keeping track of all that stuff so that
we can let it detach it and everything
is pretty much done so if that is
successful we of course set our render
ID to our program we'll do that as the
last thing that we actually do so that
it in case we run into this for example
it doesn't happen and that looks pretty
good to me
so now we need to fix it up for this and
that's pretty simple as well
basically all we need to do is create
that shader sources thing so STD
unordered and I'll just copy it I was
going to type it out and then always the
one with what I do that so we'll create
this sources thing alright and then in
two sources we will add GL vertex shader
to be our vertex sauce and then GL
fragment shader of course to be our
fragment sauce so fragment sauce alright
and then now we can pass this in to
compile will call this sources and
that's pretty much it right so we've
basically and we now support reading in
from a file and splitting it up and
doing all that stuff but also you can
just apply it manually so we've got both
of these now we can test out both of
these right so back in the sandbox app
texture shader don't reset so Hazel say
to create this now becomes basically
what we test it out before which i think
is that's here so this is our texture
shader right so we'll take this share to
create that we wrote before and we'll
just put what's pop it into yeah hey so
okay to create and i think that should
be pretty good this is our flat color
shader which i think are we still using
we're not using just a texture shader
are we okay well we had a triangle here
let's maybe I don't know if I want to
bring back the triangle so we've got
this auto we should still have our grid
right that's our flat color shader so
that way we're test if but the texture
shader which is loaded from a file and
then also the black collar shader which
isn't
make sure whether those work like
they're supposed to and of course to get
some compilation issues so let's take a
look right so Jill enum undeclared
identifier that's because we're not
including OpenGL in the header file so
we can just do that
of course it's totally fine because the
only place that
we include that header file is going to
be inside our shared of those CBP which
means that we never actually see that GL
had a file inside the sandbox out
because if we did it wouldn't work
actually sir that's a good way to
validate that ok another build error
it's ok so it looks like we are
including in the place that we shouldn't
be because it's saying it can't open it
so that is interesting I didn't think
all right we are the reason we are is
because we're being super bad for
including it here because we're actually
dynamic casting it well when we need to
actually upload uniforms because we
don't have a proper API for that so
that's terrible we definitely shouldn't
be doing that now you can see why that's
a bad idea so to kind of fix this up
really all I'm going to do is I'll get
rid of the include here I'll look at
what GL enum is right as an unsigned end
so what I can do is just move this type
def over here into our OpenGL shader so
this is of course to do remove because
it's not what we should be doing but it
will make our code work for now and the
last thing we need to do is of course
return that header file otherwise none
of our OpenGL definitions are going to
exist at all ok and as you can see we
now have this here so we're taking in
shaders both from files for this and
then also the texture shader sorry well
let me refresh that we're taking and
share is from just strings which is this
grid and then this these two textures
are being taken in from a shader that is
a file ok so pretty cool stuff we
support both files and normal shader
strings I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did you hit the like button
you can also help support the series by
going to pay for a couple special the
churner as I did it mention earlier huge
thank you to all of those supporters
that make this series possible now we
could go a lot further with this in fact
I think next episode we might we might
create something called a shader library
so at the moment what we're doing is
every time we need a shader we have to
kind of like learn it right so what we
do is we load our shader and then that's
it it's kind of maintained by ourselves
is maintained by the client that shader
object is stored in kind of a variable
that is inside
actual sandbox lair now that's not great
because if we suddenly want to use our
shader all across our engine right we
have no way of retrieving it so we need
something called a shader library which
is basically a kind of system that lets
us just ask it for a certain shade of by
a certain name so for example hey give
me the texture shader I want it and then
now we have the texture object we can
bind it when you do whatever we want
with it so that's definitely something
that we will explore probably next
episode but we'll see how we go because
there's so much stuff to come up I'll
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]